danke übrigens an den tipp mit eisen
kids ich glaube ohne dass wenn wir echt
arm dran
du kannst mal die items widerlegen mit
dem und aber wäre die kiste packen
hab ich gemacht dass ich diese ganzen
kisten voll das ist alles jeweils eine
doppel kiste steht bevor
ich würde sagen dass du dich jetzt
einmal darum gemacht und diese ganzen
sachen sortiert nach majorität klar
dabei ich habe die ganze sache jetzt
schon so sortiert du musst einfach nur
die teams du machst den komplett leeres
inventar ich habe ja schon so eine kiste
aufgebaut da kannst einfach den
inventaren legen dass ein inventar kiste
da hat niemand gesagt man kann einfach
nur noch dass das obere von maiskolben
hier abhauen aber es kann ich irgendwie
nicht kann man ja immer wieder antwort
zu machen wir es geht ja wieder
antworten wie recht keller wenn ich das
machen würde weil guck mal wenn jetzt
also mit gesagt die haut um das obere
den meisten empire müsste gleich ist
komplett ab wir müssen das labor geht
die maiskolben der rest stehen aber wie
geht das
denkste wirklich nicht durch das blicke
ich nicht durch das linke ich nicht
durch das land schafft ja also simone
machst du einfach gleichen leeres
inventar und geht es durch die kiste und
imst alle sachen aus die man nicht
braucht also so ganz normale sätze
gebraucht wenig nach vorne wie mirja und
bilder dann mache ich das ganz schön mit
bilderrahmen drüber
von welchen vorsätzen der bilderrahmen
drüber packen haben doch hier ist er so
denkt macht also glas ach so rediske
die bilderrahmen möchte ich deswegen der
regel als bilderrahmen geht auf jeden
fall in der mitte wolle und außen rum
stöcker dann weil ich möchte nämlich
darüber bilder ansetzen
ich mache so ein ton keller oder so was
war ich möchte gerne das ist alles so
ein zertifikat sie wollen niemanden hier
kannst du im rheinpark und dann nimmst
du einfach die ganze sache raus wie zum
beispiel puls oder so was brauchen wir
einfach nicht das kann immer dann
wegschmeißen
nein ich weiß müssen wir machen ich bin
messe ich weiß gar nichts ja oder tust
du gegen die scheiß gesagt hier ist auf
jeden fall so könnt ihr gleich unserer
farm und neben der nachricht habe noch
eine andere nachricht bekommen und zwar
in replay zufolge 24 wo du anfangs die
sachen zu bauen also gute der rezept ist
sehr verwirrend erwarte man das
überhaupt so da braucht wird ach so da
sagt das mit den features allerdings
machte das ist normaler typ also keine
ahnung also ich hab ich nichts mehr was
wir jetzt mal so machen sollten übrigens
extractor werde ich mich dann gleich
noch mal drum kümmern aber sonst würde
ich sagen bücherregale und kühe brauchen
wir wir müssen wir die kühe pas du ja ja
die wollen wir den wahren michael path
nochmal wird weiter damit nur mit weizen
genau wie weizen aber schon ziemlich
cool
wir haben samen haben wir das weiße
fleck wir haben eigentlich
wir haben schon eins zwei drei vier fünf
oder so und davor stehen noch mehr ganz
noch mehr erholen
manchmal wissen größeres gehege sind die
quälerei ich glaub ich hab beide sa ich
habe beide weizen einer kugel gebe ich
vollidiot
bitte partys mit dir selber danke jetzt
werde ich alles fertig gewesen
brauchst du die holzkisten kindern läuft
diese woche überall verstreut in den
kisten natürlich jetzt mal ja du kannst
du einfach die kisten das geht auch
jetzt einfach mal ab und drin
kolja diamant nicht verschwinden ja noch
richtig viel rabatt kiste ist alles
ich habe hier noch eine kiste für dich
da habe ich hier noch elf weise und dann
noch zehn tun daraus kannst du dir auch
noch eine kiste wochen noch eingepackt
ok und die am besten die katze nur mit
spitzer gab unglaublich und ich bräuchte
die schaufel zurück ich kann schnell
machen sind ja okay dann patente nimmt
sie jeden moment auf ok das war team
wird vom verein ssten hier
hier ist mal 128 pixel so dass jetzt
endlich machen weil die tiere polen
dafür brauchen wir allerdings weizen
hast du auch mal weizen an die pflanzen
nur die strophe erwarte ich von uns
jetzt erst mal da ist aber du kannst
einfach ich habe da noch ganz viel platz
gelassen
dadurch wird der samen raus unser feld
wächst und gedeiht konferenz sehen wir
noch so hecken zu haben ja ich habe
heute schon gesehen wir aber noch zu
wenig sagen
heineken ist befehl wird das beste bier
eigentlich also so richtiges bier jetzt
vom richtigen bier her sonst trinke ich
eigentlich fast gar kein bier weil ich
weiss nicht bier schmecken nicht mehr so
natürlich und einer kiste packen werden
bilden wir aber ich denke generell nicht
so gut wie gar kein alibi jetzt noch
reisen er hat sie mir das ganze gleich
anderen ofen backen wenn jetzt mehrere
kohle liegt hier auch bei älteren ja
kohle brauche ich colo colo colo colo
colo oder jetzt überall kohle
wachstumskerne haben wir flachs haben
wir alle möglichen sammeln
doch kakaobohne ist ein witz da geht's
ja wo ist denn die verdammte kohle
dabei kamen uns irgendwann sagen die
pole ist er kann man eigentlich nicht
auch zu dienst machen
zu ihren normal oder geht das nicht ein
rentner kids zu normal meinen experten
gehen ja meine da ist schon wieder
schmerzvoll einfach nur voll mit
kreativität und immer wenn ich niese da
kommt die ganze kreativität draußen dann
entsteht ein video
so ist das immer ein konkreter okay gute
nacht cornelia ein gute nacht
wir können eigentlich perfekten schnitt
setzen sind allerdings bei sechs minuten
gerade das werde ich glaube auch
leichter ich habe jetzt aber direkt in
der aufnahme taschentuch danke
unterhalten sie wollen ja ich werde sie
tun sagt also nicht so spannt bei mir
halt immer wieder zu kräften zurück dann
könnt ihr taschentuch sehen
jetzt hab ich mich eigentlich relativ
viel besser ist der radiosprecher in
zukunft ja ich hab ich hab' ich habe mir
ein lebenslauf gerade geschrieben ein
radiosender
weil einige von meinen freunden die
nicht mal wissen dass ich das mit
youtube machte die weiß sowieso kannst
vollblut so und radio passen von der
stimme und et cetera und blau und pp und
damit das auch gerade und dann habe ich
mich doch einfach mal beworben und er
muss schauen ob ich angenommen was denke
werde ich angenommen oder nicht schreibt
sind was ich jetzt mache ich erstmal
erholen ich fand's jetzt alle möglichen
sachen an weil ich hab so komisches
bekommen das hat die heißen hennig
anzieht ich weiß nicht was die bringen
ich habe doch an klasse davon einfach
mal drei angepflanzt
so hier kann ich erstmal die ganzen wenn
du irgendwelche weizens sei egal ich
habe hier schon einige ich habe ich
getan habe im knochen wieder drüber
damit wir ein bisschen links haben
das wäre noch keine sterne raquel schafe
du musst will ich schon ich kümmere mich
einfach um die famitsu ein bisschen hast
du ich meine wo du kannst
wir haben vorhin wieder vize pitsch
sachen gemacht also mit in rochester und
so was alles und wird es wird sich als
sachen also dann läutet hört man ganz
genau zu viele meinen ja immer mit
kabeln und ja also wir uns jetzt erstmal
die wesentlichen sachen gekümmert und
wir werden das immer so ein bisschen
abwechseln wir haben doch jetzt in rabat
farm und alles möglich also stellt
einfach mal und dann wird sich das
schnell ihn also wie schon oft gesagt er
müsse sich jetzt als letzte beatles
places play together sehen mit der
tradition ist elemente bei der zukunft
dazustoßen werden langfristig
unterhaltsam zu machen ich erst mal ein
korn von dir klar für uns beide das hast
du nicht verdient wo bist du eigentlich
gerade da ist er auf der suche nach
wolle also noch schaffen
ja ich finde im wald gehen aber krass
fiel ich hoffe ich schaffe ich den 2 3
anschluss wieder zurückgelaufen ich kann
ich bin jung bist ein richtiges talent
der richtige stil von wo kommst du dir
zurück fordert läuft auch wie sie
schmeißt die hearings rutter was fressen
und jetzt sieht man kommt mal wo ich hin
wo ich ihn schlage da da dabei die
brücke wo wir damit die brücke hatten da
sind tiere okay holst du es machst eine
tierfarm da eine große debatte ich hole
die tiere und du machst die kisten
sortieren ja aber ich hole zwar ein
bisschen wolle
und du willst du mal an die tiere für
uns für die zukunft besser aber töten
die tiere bis nicht nein ich habe doch
die wollen mit einer schere gesetzt
wo war eigentlich die beine hoch
fertigmachen reisen hoch ich meine wir
machen noch ein großes feld was das
ganze als erstes wieder mit den genuss
der verbrennungsofen nein das ist dann
nicht mehr legal warte ich noch ganz
viel aus stein zwar sehr sehr erbärmlich
aber egal
hey mann wir müssen viel zu leicht die
portalsoftware wo ist eigentlich los ist
ja vor allem weil die portals letzte mal
weg gegangen
wir könnten eigentlich jetzt irgendwo
anders hinsetzen ich habe jetzt einfach
mal neuenstein hausgemacht doch die
sollten reichen
wer spielt natürlich lange im spiel drin
sind da würde ich mich freuen wieder
richtig viel mit der portugal machen
dass wir hier das unternehmen das wieder
verschiedene begrenzt